السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في هذه النافذه
الانسانيه الخاصه بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل
على قطاع غزه نناقش فيها تحذير برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي من خطر حدوث مجاعه في
الاشهر السته المقبله اذا استمر الوضع
الحالي في الصراع الشديد وتقييد وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه اضافه الى تحذير
الاونو ايضا من ان مستوى الجوع في غزه
اصبح غير مسبوق وان المياه والغذاء
والدواء باتت تستخدم كسلاح حرب للنقاش
سيكون معنا من عمان الاستاذ احمد بيرم
المستشار الاعلامي للشرق الاوسط في المجلس
النرويجي للاجئين لكن قبل البدء في النقاش
نذكر بحصي الشهداء جراء الحرب الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه فقد ارتفع عدد ضحايا العدوان
الاسرائيلي الى اكثر من 20 ال شهيد بحسب
المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه الجرحى
وصل عددهم الى 52000 1600 منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي بينهم طبعا
8000 طفل اضافه الى
62 امراه نذكر كذلك بالمساعدات التي دخلت
الى قطاع غزه حتى اليوم اذ تقول اخر
احصائيه للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ان عدد
الشاحنات التي دخلت قطاع غزه وصل الى
4300 وشاحنه في الفتره من الحادي والع من
اكتوبر حتى السادس ع من ديسمبر
الجاري كانت تدخل قطاع غزه قبل الحرب
حوالي 500 شاحنه يوميا هذه الحرب التي
يشنها جيش الاحتلال على غزه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي برنامج الاغذيه العالمي قال ان
جميع سكان قطاع غزه الذين يقدر عددهم بنحو
مليونين و الف يعانون على الاقل من ازمه
غذاء ومعيشه حاده اضاف البرنامج ان اكثر
من اسره من كل اربع اسر تواجه خطر الجوع
الشديد وقال ان 26% من سكان القطاع
استنفدوا تماما امدادات
الغذائيه اشار البرنامج ايضا الى ان تسعه
اشخاص من كل عشره اشخاص يقضون يوما على
الاقل بدون طعام ولا يعرفون من اين ستاتي
الوجبه المقبله منظمه الصحه العالميه من
بها قالت ان 93% من سكان قطاع غزه يواجهون
ازمه جوع غير مسبوقه اذا معنا من عمان
الاستاذ احمد بيرم المستشار الاعلامي
للشرق الاوسط في المجلس النرويجي
للاجئين يعني الجميع يتحدث عن ازمه جوع
يعني هنالك من شهاده لطبيب يقول انه اكثر
ما كان يؤلم
ان مرضى الذين يعانون من جروح
خطيره حينما يستيقظون وحينما تاتي لهم
الفرصه
ويصرخون بدل ان يطلبوا مسكنات للالم او
مخدر اثناء اجراء العمليات الجراحيه
يطلبون الشر بت ماء هذا وضع غير مسبوق
ربما في اي حرب اليس
كذلك مساء الخير استاذ زين العابدين يعني
بالفعل يعني شهاده مفجعه حاله كحال كثير
من الشهادات التي نسمع نسمعها من فرقنا
كنت اتحدث الى احد زملائي البارحه كان كنت
اسال ما ما يعني هل يوجد اي شيء يمكن
للاطفال يعني تناوله و ذكر لي انه اذا
حصلت على علبه من الطعام
المعلب فهذا
انجاز فهذا انجاز لك
ولعائلتك يعني بالحديث عن المقارنه مع بعض
الدول الاخرى وبعض الازمات الانسانيه التي
شهدناها عبر السنوات الاخيره يعني ما يحصل
الارقام التي نشهدها ونوصل نصل الى حاله
مجاعه ما بين 50 ل 55% من السكان في غزه
هذا رقم
فاق حالات ك يعني ازمات طويله كسوريا
الازمه السوريه الازمه ال الغذائيه في
سوريا والازمه الغذائيه في اليمن المرحله
الخامسه ولتسهيل يعني توضيح هذه الارقام
للسيده المشاهدين نتحدث عن موت ممكن ان
ينتج من سوء التغذيه الحاد او من المجاعه
او ما يسمى ب
ا حاله الموت بدون صدمات او الحاله الموت
بدون سبب صادم او بمعنى اخر كل ما يحصل
يمكن منعه يمكن منعه من خلال السماح لتدفق
الشاحنات
التي التي تنتظر على الطرف الاخر في في
مصر وفتح المعبر ك كرم سالم فتح معبر بشكل
بشكل مستمر تثير الحقيقه كثير من من من
الاسئله لانه الناس الذين يريدون مساعده
غزه يشعرون باحباط
شديد لانه لا يعلمون اذا تبرعوا وقدموا ما
ما بيدهم ان ان هذا سيصل يعني 4000 شاحنه
منذ اكثر من 72 يوما هذا رقم قليل جدا
بالنظر لاحتياجات السكان ما ما ما الذي
يمكن قوله لمن يريد ان يساعد غزه لكن يعلم
ان الشاحنات ستتعثر عند بب
الرفع سؤال
سؤال سؤال جيد جدا يعني 75 يوم نحاول
الاجابه على هذا السؤال
ا ويعني يمكن الاعتراف
ب حتى في المجال الانساني للمنظمات
العامله في في المجال الانساني ما ما ما
نفعله بالكاد
يعني يشكل 5% ما كنا مما كنا نفعله حتى في
ظل ضربات وصراع وازمات مرت بها غزه كنا
دائما موجودين على الارض نقدم المساعده
الان فريقي فريق
زملائي 50 50 زميل يعني يفعلون ما بوسعهم
لتقديم الوجبات
تقديم الخيم للاسف الان الناس نزحت وتسكن
في الخيم تقديم بعض المياه النظيفه
المنظمات تسعى وتحاول ويعني من ابناء غزه
نفسهم هؤلاء يعني الابطال صراحه يعني حال
كحال الطبيب والصحفي العامل
الانساني ما
ي وصفه
جوتيريش وضع يعني صعب يائس كثير كثيرون
تحدثوا عن انه عمال الانقاذ وعمال الاغاثه
يشعرون بالياس لانه ليس بوسع شيء لكن
الارقام التي ذكرناها عن المجاعه هذا عن
المناطق التي امكن الوصول اليها ماذا عن
الشمال هل هي تشمل الشمال ايضا
صحيح تشمل الشمال نعم واعتقد يعني الرقم
في الشمال رقم هائل جدا نتحدث عن المجاعه
وهي المستوى الخامس هنالك اربع مستويات
اخرى من سوق الغذاء ونقص الغذاء وكما يعني
تفضلت حضرتك المناطق الشماليه لا يمكن
الوصول الى جميعها ماس اكيد سوف يكون
هنالك عينات نستدل من خلالها على الارقام
هذه الارقام يعني نتحدث عن ثلث قد وصلوا
الى المرحله الخامسه وهي المرحله الاخيره
يعني للاسف من بعد نتحدث عن مجاعه نتحدث
عن حالات وفيات وكان هنك تقارير عن حالات
وفيات ناتجه عن عن الطعام يعني هذا بغض
النظر عن الحديث عن عن المياه الغير نظيفه
والملوث وعن الامراض التي نشهدها في غزه
والتي لم نشهدها ولم نعرف بها اصلا بسبب
عدم يعني يعني وجود طاقات وجود الطاقه
الاستيعابيه
يعني ل تطبيب هذه الحالات يعني ما نشاهده
يعني حتى كان اضيف انه الانقطاع في
الاتصالات عن عن المناطق الشماليه يعني
اصبح من الشبه مستحيل ان تعرف ماذا ماذا
يحصل يعني زملاء لي للاسف يعني يتحدثون عن
عدم قدرتهم على الاطمئنان على افراد
عائلتهم في الشمال ف ما حال يعني المنظمات
التي تسعى لفهم يعني
وتجرب ان ان تحصل على بعض المعلومات اعتقد
من دون وقف اطلاق نار وهذا ما يتحدث عنه
التقرير الاممي من دون وقف اطلاق النار
وفي حال استمر الوضع الى الى المزيد من
التدهور نتحدث عن سته شهور هي الاسوا
لربما في تاريخ غزي اشكرك شكرا جزيلا طبعا
نتمنى الا يطول الامر بعذابات هؤلاء
المساكين في
غزه اكثر من ذلك ليصل لسته اشهر هذا
السيناريو كابوس لكن نشكرك من عمان احمد
بيرم المستشار الاعلامي للشرق الاوسط في
المجلس النرويجي
للاجئين ختام هذه النافذه في امان الله